this morning looking at data statistics
we very very brief he looked at survey
is what to ask like the questions you're
gonna ask and how you ask it at the
different kinds of dhania resulting from
them then I'm up to what and how the
very obvious question that we didn't ask
was well who are you going to give these
questions who are you going to talk now
oops here to ask this question has two
answers to it really what is really
expensive and time-consuming and almost
always impossible and the other one is
kind of like a compromise that has lots
of disadvantages to it so next week
everyone's house always going to be
doing that census right the census is
the first answer to the question of
video ask and first the armed services
just ask everyone okay now it would be a
little more specific from that will we
say everyone a census is asking everyone
I'll just give me a little bit more
specifically to say everyone in the
target population everyone in the target
population now that phrase tiger
population is pretty important so let's
just underline that right the type of
population is well the question you're
asking who they are relevant to you
right depending on what you're asking
baby you know adults are irrelevant to
your survey or baby students are
irrelevant to your survey well maybe
people in another country etc etc right
so the target population is who is your
survey relevant to yeah like this
particular generation yeah you could
slice it up how if you like a particular
generation or men or women only
whichever four have other answers you
have so who is the survey or the
questions relevant to
but of course everyone knows a census
while it's going to give you it's got
your best chance for accurate responses
it's like guarantee by the way could
still be inaccurate what's the very
disadvantage of doing a sentence a
census there's a lot of people yeah
that's right like if you're say
absolutely everyone it's expensive it's
time-consuming which is another way of
saying it's expensive and as a result
it's often it often just copied on like
it's it's impossible where it's
impractical to do which is why this
whole idea of doing the census once
every five years it's a big deal
everyone's gotta stay put the particular
place to do it otherwise you welcome to
the email you're done so since I
differences they're wonderful they've
got the best chance for accuracy but
they're very hot ok so does anyone know
what it's called when you don't ask
absolutely everyone starts with an S
whoa it is a selection right this
special word they use for it is a sample
okay so maybe you thought you've heard
this phrase before so simple is just a
portion of target population
it's a portion now clearly this is um
this is being devised to overcome these
exact problems here but it's solving
these problems of expensive time and
practicality it's on introduces its own
problems if you're only interviewing or
questioning a small group of people what
kinds of problems before your sample
size is quite small so you might not
have a cure
okay good so the whole idea is but I'll
talk about that in a second all idea is
you have a small portion right and then
you extrapolate from that data out to
the entire population but that might not
be accurate at all so you're gonna say
it's just less accurate because you're
not talking to absolutely everybody
right you can introduce we talked about
reporting bias cognitive bias you can
introduce sample bias and I'm gonna talk
in detail about this in a second before
I give you off road use of examples
sample bias is okay your answers to your
questions are all gonna be inclined in a
particular direction precisely because
of who exactly you're asking okay so I
will love I'll talk about that in a
second but can we just talk about some
examples when are you actually going to
get like a sample that you guys
encounter in daily experience let's say
what place assuming workplace MA you're
almost guaranteed that not everyone's
gonna answer the survey cause like if
you don't make it compulsory it's just a
who's got time for that the cases of
people are going to skip it and
definitely always notice you when it was
like you know the whole table shortened
that kind of thing there are an election
polls right now when I was little I
always understood election polls because
you know a lot of views they say thirty
five percent of voters vote for this guy
right and I was like well if we go
through five percent of voters haven't
we already done yet yeah make sure they
do we need to continue and what I did
not understand was clearly they weren't
obviously asked you everyone they're
just talking about a portion of the
population so just ask us walk urban
people they might ask say you know let's
just think about it this way the
population of Australia the last other I
had in my head was twenty four billion I
think it might be a bit more than that
maybe twenty six
so let's stick back to your work with
you in ratios under under mmm one okay
if I say asked 2,400 people 2,400 people
and then I say well okay what is that in
relation to the whole population of
Australia what is that what's the
relationship between them sweet four
zero zero zero zero zero zero but it
looks like to me it's ten thousand times
ten thousand times yes ten thousand
times fewer than the whole population
right so I could say within this group
of people you know if some number of the
vote for this or that I'm gonna multiply
that by ten thousand to try to
extrapolate so the entire tiger
populations okay so election pause a
thing I want I write down for you is
teeming ratings and as they don't know
what the name of the company that
organizes TV ratings is in Australia
it's a company called AC Nielsen and the
only reason I know that it's called AC
abusin is because I was actually part of
for like a year and a half the sample of
the population we had a little box
attached there TV and every time I
turned on the TV the box would switch on
and I actually had a special remote for
this box instead okay who's watching
right and the botton you all of the ages
of the people in my household all five
of us and I'd say okay I'm watching and
watching there's all the bit ages and
they say okay from there
clearly not everyone has such a box in
their house I don't have it anymore
they've moved on to someone else they're
going to say like have you ever wondered
like oh three point four million people
watch the finale for Game of Thrones
this you know this week it's like how do
they know that didn't count the answer
is no they did something like this right
they took a small portion of the
population maybe one ten thousandth of
the population they said how many of
those people are watching and then they
multiplied a lot there was a little more
to it than that that's the basic idea
so all of these kinds of ways of doing
it yeah these problems of a sample bias
right this is very very important so we
need to think about the kinds of
problems that can emerge and I'm gonna
give you some examples of who you gets
asked and therefore what you sort of
workshop with me what kinds of problems
are going to emerge you so we talked
about the four ways and posing questions
to people do you remember what the four
ways were you think back like an hour
and a half
what were the four ways like after
you've got your questions how do you
pose that to people okay number one face
to face will go from like most explicit
to least expected after face to face
there was the phone interviews there
paper and there okay so those in or in
order of price right now if I say did a
phone survey right and if I did it for
instance let's say 10:00 a.m. on a
Monday okay yeah hey these are doing
right today I'm on a Monday right and I
rain people's homes Oh Kate I've got to
get a portion of the time population
there are people who to people but yeah
I case so who will it be
and the answer is it's obviously gonna
be skewed towards retirees who are you
know working anymore who else are they
going to be skewed toward people who are
unemployed stay-at-home moms and dads
all that kind of thing right full-time
students etc what we're doing so you can
see just by asking it a particular way
a simple biases introduced does that
make sense
you know election polls and that kind of
thing let's think about as another
example what if you go to a particular
area right so if you want to do like a
paper questionnaire you're limited like
you've got to physically go somewhere
okay what problems might emerge if
you're doing like if you go to an area
in general extra pot what may happen
yeah fantastic so some areas I clearly
think yes this is definitely coalition
always it definitely label a people be
able to in Slam victory so depending on
where you go a new sample bias gets
introduced
okay well suppose I want to overcome
that I want to go into a place where I'm
going to get people from all over so
maybe I go to like Central Station
Central Station right like if I go to a
train station the Natura train station
is you get people from all over some try
to solve this problem but in doing so
thank you you should new poll ok people
at sexual I'm all in a hurry to go
somewhere yeah absolutely only people
I'm gonna get very graceful Sinemet but
even further than you who are the kinds
of people are getting if I go to a
workstation a train table ok
only the kind of people who are
commuting that particular way